I have two stories for you today about
French president Emmanuel macron one is
more serious the other one is just sort
of funny let's start with the serious
one I've spoken before about how dealing
with Donald Trump is sort of like
dealing with a petulant child sometimes
you have to be strict with them
sometimes you have to humor them
sometimes you have to ignore them
altogether and do the adult stuff when
they're distracted or not in the room
and Emmanuel macron has used some
toddler level reverse psychology to
completely get Donald Trump to change
his public tune on NATO Donald Trump as
you might know has been denouncing NATO
attacking NATO criticizing NATO for a
very long time NATO is a treaty it
includes 29 countries mostly for shared
military defense support Trump is of
course in the UK for meetings the for a
NATO summit and there have been some
really good articles including one in
The Washington Post about how a lot of
care is being taken to prevent Donald
Trump from ruining anything and this
includes inviting Trump to dinner at
Buckingham Palace and some other
festivities private meetings with
different world leaders all sorts of
different stuff to try to prevent Donald
Trump from ruining the entire thing so
Emmanuel macron the French president
took a bit of a different approach the
French President started last month
being a little critical himself of NATO
in a pretty narrow way talking about the
brain death of NATO talking about issues
with NATO but at no point is it really
in question that Francis of course a
strong NATO ally partner and supporter
but word got to trump hey Emmanuel
macron is saying these things so what is
Donald Trump do well of course he says
no no no McCrone is wrong yesterday
Donald Trump declared that NATO serves a
great purpose pushing back against
McCrone saying that McCrone is wrong and
France really needs NATO quote from
Donald Trump
NATO serves a great purpose and I hear
that president McCrone said NATO is a
brain-dead I think that's very insulting
to a lot of different forces when you
make a statement like that that is a
very very nasty statement 228 including
them 28 countries check this out he
went further talking about how France
needs NATO look at this clip
nobody needs data more than France you
just look back over the last long period
of time
nobody needs NATO mother France and
frankly the one that benefits really the
least is the United States we benefit
the least we're helping Europe Europe
unites and they go against a common foe
that maybe it may not be your foe can
tell you that but there are other folks
out there also but I think nobody needs
it more than France and that's why I
think that when friends makes a
statement like they made about NATO
that's a very dangerous this is how you
manipulate kids right for years
world leaders have been struggling how
do we get trump to stop attacking nato
how do we get the President of the
United States to stop undermining NATO
in comes the French president makes one
comment about hey here's an issue with
NATO and next thing you know Trump sees
the opportunity to criticize a European
leader and in he goes defending NATO
more strongly than he arguably has ever
done during his entire presidency this
is the type of reverse psychology that
parents use on toddlers in general when
a kid is like four or five or you know
maybe six years old this type of reverse
psychology stops working because it's
too transparent and the kid learns what
it is that you're trying to do on Donald
Trump it still works brilliantly
executed by Emmanuel macron European
leaders all say NATO is good NATO is
good so Trump has to say no no no NATO
is bad McCrone slips in NATO is sort of
maybe not that great in this one
specific way and all of a sudden a flaw
switch flips I was about to say a flip
switches a switch flips and NATO is good
for Donald Trump nicely done by Emmanuel
macron and now let's get on to the
funnier Trump McCrone story from
yesterday
so let's now get to the absolute
ignorant propaganda disinformation nonce
from the NATO summit Donald Trump as the
world leaders were laughing at him as
they said during that hot mike moment
that we talked about already Donald
Trump took some questions in the UK they
talked about how Trump was late because
he answered questions for 40 minutes or
something and his staff was wondering
what on earth is going on those 40
minutes were riddled with ridiculous
ignorant malignant disinformation and
propaganda and it did not go well being
upstaged by French president Emmanuel
macron which I'll get to a little bit
later on in the show but when the topic
of climate change came up during Trump's
press conference yesterday sort de-facto
press conference this is one of the four
most international and geopolitical
issues of our time Donald Trump's brain
appeared to malfunction or glitch and he
seemed unable to stop saying ridiculous
things we're gonna look at a couple of
clips this is again this is really
tragic because it's not just that Trump
isn't making sense on the topic of
climate change he's actively making the
problem worse he's not working with
other world leaders on the issue of
climate he's sending us back years in
dealing with the problem here's the
first clip Trump was asked whether he
thinks about climate change the concept
of asking Trump what he thinks about I
find funny I don't know why and Trump
says he believes very strongly in very
very crystal clear water and air this is
what it sounds like to have no idea what
you're talking about
climate changes are important to me and
I've done many environmental impacts
sapiens over my life
I believe in I believe very strongly and
very very crystal clear clean water and
clean air that's a big part of climate
change I also see what's happening with
our oceans where certain countries are
dumping unlimited loads of things in
there they float they tend to float
forward the United States I see that
happening and nobody's ever seen
anything like it
and it's gotten worse but no it's very
important to me also but I want clean
air and clean water with the number one
member he believes in crystal-clear
water very strongly I guess that's good
to know
but this is the way that a simpleton
understands an issue which is fine if
you're not President of the United
States
we don't need simplistic understandings
of the foremost issues of our time held
by the President of the United States
certain countries are dumping in the
oceans well what about us Donald because
we're doing that as well then a reporter
good for the reporter tries to drill
down a little more specifically into
this issue since Trump mentioned the
oceans the reporter asks about rising
sea levels and Trump with the generic
everything concerns me message shifts
over to talking about nuclear weapons
which wasn't even the point of the
question nuclear proliferation which i
think is a very important topic and it's
a topic that we're going to discuss
today you know the whole situation with
nuclear to me is very very important as
we've been discussing today at the
various meetings that we've had I think
that's something that has to be taken
care of and it has to be dealt with very
strongly that whole situation with
nuclear is important what had the ocean
oh yeah that to shore then Trump is
asked so you're here for a NATO summit
the whole point of NATO is it's a shared
defence agreement member countries come
to the defense of other member countries
if they are attacked militarily the US
would do that right mr. president well
Trump won't commit to that
which again is the whole point of NATO
Trump says if the country hasn't paid
what he thinks they should pay maybe we
won't defend them I guess is the point
here the link went as you put it in
paying for their defense things when you
commit as president of the United States
to defend them if they were attacked
well you know I'm going to be discussing
that today and it's a very interesting
question isn't it and you know it also
depends on what your definition of
delinquents is for instance if you have
a country that's paying only 1% and you
have something better paying less than
1% and they should be you have something
to pay so Trump just going off and
talking about other things do other
countries Oh back fees but not answering
the question would the United States
come to the defense of NATO member
nations as is the point of NATO's
existence but then hilariously and this
is so funny the Dow fell hundreds of
points yesterday and Trump was asked
about it while on screen the Dow was
down like more than 400 points and Trump
said that he doesn't watch the stock
markets which is so funny because on any
day that the stock market does well
Trump's tweeting about it Trump's
bragging about it Trump's using that to
justify that he has the best economy of
any president and you know the history
of the United States but yesterday was a
bad day for stocks and Crump says oh I
don't really pay attention to the stock
market but if the stock market goes up
with their I don't watch the stock i
watch jobs jobs are what i watch i watch
making the proper deal we've been taking
advantage of the United States by China
for so many years okay just one more and
we could go on all day with these Trump
was asked about the house intelligence
committees impeachment report here is
what Donald from said now I can't even
make heads or tails out of this one I
know at one point he seems to be talking
about that supposed Ukraine call
transcript which is of course not a
transcript it's like just a few
paragraphs and then I guess he starts
attacking Adam Schiff that's what we
have a perfectly
beautiful 3/4 page transcription and
then in the other case the 2 page
transcription of the conversation but a
lot of people didn't read that how many
people call you a friend of my girl
about the top person in New York all
about great friend of mine very
successful gee I didn't like what was
said I said oh where did you see it did
you read it no I didn't read that I
heard Adam Schiff give it I said well
that's not what was said and I sent him
a copy of what was said he said this is
like this is great this isn't what he
said this guy he said he made up the
conversation Eli if he didn't do that in
the halls of Congress he'd be thrown
into jail but he did it in the halls of
Congress and he's given immunity this is
a sick person he's a liar
this is why world leaders are laughing
at him
what on earth is this guy talking about
it makes me cringe it's really
embarrassing and we'll see today whether
Trump ruins NATO by the time this clip
is out we may know what impact Trump has
had on sort of the core NATO summit
meetings that are taking place today
Trump tweeting earlier about his meeting
with a trumpian British prime minister
Boris Johnson of course saying it was
all absolutely great and fantastic I
wonder if Boris Johnson participating
and making fun of Trump yesterday and
that video came up my guess would be no
but we will see what actually comes from
the NATO summit discussions later today
leave a reply about this if you're
watching on YouTube what do you think
explains Trump's seemingly a cute brain
malfunction in these video clips or send
me a tweet at D Pakman quick break back
after this with much more I have two
stories for you today about French
president Emmanuel macron one is more
serious the other one is just sort of
funny let's start with the serious one
I've spoken before about how dealing
with Donald Trump is sort of like
dealing with a petulant child sometimes
you have to be strict with them
sometimes you have to humor them
sometimes you have to ignore them
altogether and do the adult stuff when
they're distracted or not in the room
and Emmanuel macron has used some
toddler level reverse psychology to
completely get Donald Trump to change
his public tune on NATO Donald
as you might know has been denouncing
NATO attacking NATO criticizing NATO for
a very long time NATO is a treaty it
includes 29 countries mostly for shared
military defence support Trump is of
course in the UK for meetings the for a
NATO summit and there have been some
really good articles including one in
The Washington Post about how a lot of
care is being taken to prevent Donald
Trump from ruining anything and this
includes inviting Trump to dinner at
Buckingham Palace and some other
festivities private meetings with
different world leaders all sorts of
different stuff to try to prevent Donald
Trump from ruining the entire thing so
Emmanuel macron the French president
took a bit of a different approach the
French president started last month
being a little critical himself of NATO
in a pretty narrow way talking about the
brain death of NATO talking about issues
with NATO but at no point is it really
in question that Francis of course a
strong NATO ally partner and supporter
but word got to trump hey Emmanuel
macron is saying these things so what is
Donald Trump do well of course he says
no no no McCrone is wrong yesterday
Donald Trump declared that NATO serves a
great purpose pushing back against
McCrone saying that McCrone is wrong and
France really needs NATO quote from
Donald Trump
NATO serves a great purpose and I hear
that president McCrone said NATO is a
brain-dead I think that's very insulting
to a lot of different forces when you
make a statement like that that is a
very very nasty statement 228 including
them 28 countries check this out
he even went further talking about how
France needs NATO look at this clip
nobody needs data more than France you
just look back over the last long period
of time
nobody needs NATO one of the friends and
frankly the one that benefits really the
least is the United States we
but the least we're helping euro Europe
unites and they go against a common foe
that maybe it may not be your foe can
tell you that but there are other phones
out there also but I think nobody needs
it more than France and that's why I
think that when friends makes a
statement like they made about NATO
that's a very dangerous for them this is
how you manipulate kids right for years
world leaders have been struggling how
do we get Trump to stop attacking NATO
how do we get the President of the
United States to stop undermining NATO
in comes the French president makes one
comment about hey here's an issue with
NATO and next thing you know Trump sees
the opportunity to criticize a European
leader and in he goes defending NATO
more strongly than he arguably has ever
done during his entire presidency this
is the type of reverse psychology that
parents use on toddlers in general when
a kid is like four or five or you know
maybe six years old this type of reverse
psychology stops working because it's
too transparent and the kid learns what
it is that you're trying to do on Donald
Trump it still works brilliantly
executed by Emmanuel macron European
leaders all say NATO is good NATO is
good so Trump has to say no no no NATO
is bad McCrone slips in NATO is sort of
maybe not that great in this one
specific way and all of a sudden a flaw
switch flips I was about to say a flip
switch is a switch flips and NATO is
good for Donald Trump nicely done by
Emmanuel macron and now let's get on to
the funnier Trump McCrone story from
yesterday I have some really great video
for you today from a top contender for
the most delusional Trump voter into
come in the in the United States last
week during a livestream that I did on
YouTube and twitch we happen to overlap
with some of Donald Trump's Magga rally
in Florida and Fox News sent a reporter
actually let's call him a guy with a
microphone I think better said they sent
a guy with a microphone to arrest her
in Boca Raton Florida the day after the
rally and they happened to come across a
business owner of a security company
this is all self professed I don't know
if any of the stuff is true a guy who
says he owns a security company who
hires lots of veterans who says he used
to be a Democrat but is now fully
backing Trump this guy says he is all in
with Trump because he's patriotic and he
supports Family Values and he's honest
this is Trump and has integrity of
character and has delivered on his
promises I present to you today the man
that might be the most delusional
Trump voter in the country at least a
top contender for that position and
notice as you watch this video how sure
of himself this man seems sir what's
your name and what do you do my name is
Ronnie Joseph and I run a security
company run security coming we were
talking you hire a bunch of vets we
appreciate that for sure you now
you used to be a Democrat now you're a
Republican you support the president why
that change and why do you support
President Trump well for me it's it's
really quite simple it's about family
values is about being a patriotic
American and it just comes down to being
honest and truthful to who you are
that's what I put you know that's what I
value family values honesty integrity
character and that's everything that
President Trump represents you feel like
he's delivered on the promises that he
absolutely absolutely he has facts do
not matter
Trump is patriotic and supports family
values is honest has integrity of
character and has delivered on promises
is there anything that guy said that's
true is it even true that this guy used
to be a Democrat maybe that's the one
thing the guy said that it's true he's
with Trump on the issue of Family Values
Trump who has had not only endless
affairs and seems to barely even know
some of his children but is paid off
some of his mistresses was involved with
people whose names I can't even say
because as soon as you say certain names
you get demonetized on YouTube but I
think you all know who I'm talking about
those family values Trump's family
values have this voter gushing over
Donald Trump he's with Trump over
Trump's honesty Trump is the
most dishonest president by number of
lies of any president that we are aware
of
he's with Trump over integrity of
character Trump operates like a con man
wanna me mafia boss there is nothing
further from integrity of character than
Donald Trump
this guy is with Trump because Trump has
delivered on his promises what he was
gonna fix health care and get rid of
Obamacare didn't happen he was gonna
build a wall didn't happen he was going
to fix trade that seems to have gone the
opposite direction he was going to
improve the reputation of the US around
the world
no the US isn't even included in many
important conversations happening
internationally because of Donald Trump
in the Oval Office the only value that
this guy seems to share with Donald
Trump is extraordinary hypocrisy that is
the one area where they seem to overlap
this is the twilight zone this is why
facts don't matter and this is why I've
been saying for years we can't waste our
time on these people imagine that you
meet someone who says listen I think
Trump's a scumbag liar who's
embarrassing the u.s. around the world
but I'm gonna be honest with you his tax
plan is good for me personally so I'll
probably vote for him we can work with
that okay we can talk about you know
listen even if it seems like Trump's tax
plan is good for you because you've got
more money in your pocket it's actually
not good for you in that by hurting
others it creates societal cost like my
point is we can have a conversation with
someone who believes that if you meet
someone who says I love Trump he's
honest he has integrity of character he
has family values that I agree with he
fulfilled his promises by I mean that's
a conversation ender there is no point
and it's actually so absurd this video
that I had people tweeting me over the
weekend saying David this guy has to be
a plant but I actually think a plant
would be less ignorant we cannot win by
convincing these people we have to win
despite them period and we might not
sadly there may be enough tens of
millions of people like that guy who
voted for Trump in 2016 and are going to
vote for him again in 2020 that we may
lose and that's why get out the vote
so important let me know what you think
about this video leave a reply if you're
watching on YouTube otherwise send me a
tweet at D Pakman follow me there as
well we'll take a quick break so much to
talk about today back from Thanksgiving
and much has happened so world leaders
have been caught on a candid video
recording mocking Donald Trump and while
Republicans are absolutely outraged at
the fact that there was a recording
there is nothing at all surprising about
this and I'm going to explain why to you
today besides the obvious reasons as you
know if you've been paying attention to
politics and you're not blinded by
partisanship or ignorance Donald Trump
has made the United States the
laughingstock of the world and has
caused the u.s. to not be taken
seriously on a whole host of issues at
the top of the list of course climate
change but also trade foreign policy
within geopolitical alliances and in the
context of treaties being close to the
top of the list in sort of a shared way
Trump is not invited to lots of
important conversations on these issues
Trump has often been condescended to at
meetings of world leaders and there have
been pictures of Trump being talked to
like he's a little kid in a roomful of
world leaders now this is all public any
sensible person would guess that in
private world leaders are absolutely
sick of Trump well Trump is now at the
NATO summit in the UK I'll have more
coverage of that later in the show and
world leaders were caught on a candid
video a sort of hot mic moment if you
will clearly ridiculing Donald Trump and
his behavior this video which we're
going to play as Canadian Prime Minister
Justin Trudeau French president Emmanuel
macron and Trump like British Prime
Minister Boris Johnson when even Boris
Johnson is part of a crowd making fun of
you you know that you are an
international laughingstock here's the
video you'll hear them talking about
Trump being late about his ridiculous
press conferences about how Trump
staffers jaws hit the floor because of
Trump's behavior now I do apologise to
people if you're merely listening it is
a little bit tough to hear it all
clearly for our video audience it is
titled let's take a look
[Music]
again when even Boris Johnson is
laughing at you you are the
laughingstock and this is a real change
for the American presidency for the
office of the presidency I'm talking
about here and I hate to see this I
really do I you know there are people
who say oh the left wants the the
economy to crash just to spite Trump or
they want the u.s. to be a laughing
stock just to spite Trump I hate this
this is horrible to see Barack Obama
disagree with his policies on many
issues he was respected internationally
he was an adult in the room he was
leading conversations of world leaders
as opposed to either being condescended
to or ignored or left out altogether I
just wish the trumpets were honest with
us admit Trump is a laughingstock and
that the u.s. is not respected but tell
us you don't care to pretend that
everybody around the world respects
Trump fears Trump it's absurd just tell
us you don't care that he's a laughing
US rat a laughingstock rather than
denying the reality Trump campaigned on
everyone is laughing at Obama and if I'm
president we're going to be respected
again as usual the opposite of trumps
campaign framing ended up being the
reality and in any case this is just one
piece of it there are lots of very
relevant things already to discuss from
the NATO summit which we're going to get
to momentarily but once again we are not
in a position of strength when world
leaders are talking together and
laughing at the President of the United
States it could not be more of a
difference from when Barack Obama was
president and again it's really
important to distinguish that doesn't
mean I agreed with Barack Obama on every
policy quite the opposite this doesn't
mean that Barack Obama was pushing the
right policy in all of those
geopolitical summits and meetings
sometimes he was sometimes he wasn't but
we weren't a laughingstock
we now are it's embarrassing it's
medic and it is not going to change not
just until Trump is removed from office
but for a while since Donald Trump has
been removed from office a lot of hot
mics this week at the NATO summit in the
UK and now Donald Trump has been caught
on one so I told you that Donald Trump
after finding out that other world
leaders were laughing about him he is a
literal laughingstock among world
leaders he threw a tantrum he left the
NATO summit early but he also insulted
Canadian Prime Minister Justin Trudeau
after that happened
Trump was caught on a recording
congratulating himself about the funny
zinger of an insult against Trudeau
calling him two-faced so let's go
through it piece by piece first here is
Donald Trump calling Justin Trudeau
two-faced you be the judge about how
much of a biting zinger criticism this
was well he's too fast I find him to be
a very nice guy but you know the truth
is that I told him out of the fact that
he's not paying 2% okay and then Trump
later really apparently thinking that
that was a great insult caught on a hot
mic saying wasn't that so funny when I
called Justin Trudeau two-faced
I was funny when I said the guy's good
first you know I oh yeah it was super
funny when you said he was two-faced
right who who else heard it because that
was really funny guys did you hear me
this is cringe-worthy this this is like
the kid in school who one time said
something that was like a 2 out of 10 on
the humour scale and then for weeks at
every opportunity brings it up remember
that time when I said that one thing oh
yeah but we're talking about something
else
oh yeah no but it reminded me of that
time where I said that really funny
thing don't don't you guys remember how
funny that was that it that's what this
reminded me of this is such an insecure
person at heart he's giving a
blow-by-blow of just a lame comeback to
remind people of how he really got the
last word and came out on top
before he fled back to his airplane and
flew back to the United States what's
super clear from this is that Donald
Trump is really embarrassed as he should
be now I know a lot of people say David
he's not embarrassed he's he's unable to
feel shame he always thinks he acted
correctly I think that it's a
combination I think it's a combination
of his delusions of grandeur but he is
embarrassed to some degree it might be
perceived as anger
he may even see it as anger but at this
point it's clear that deep down
somewhere in there there is
embarrassment there and this is all he
can do to fight back and in some sense
it's sad in another sense it is
hilarious to watch it from the sidelines
but the big picture that I want to
mention is that this is so emblematic of
the problems in the world right now
world leaders are caught expressing
concern about Donald Trump's bizarre
behavior in other words world leaders
when they think people aren't listening
or when they don't think they're being
recorded they're talking about how odd
and disturbing Donald Trump's behavior
is Trump gets hot put caught on a hot
mic and he's just praising himself for
quite frankly not very funny insult that
he told and reminding people around him
how funny it was this is a microcosm of
everything that is taking place right
now and it can't end soon enough it's
been good to have a break honestly from
the craziness of American politics for a
few days I completely checked out over
the Thanksgiving break here in the
United States one of the very clear
things that
happened while we were gone is that
Donald Trump has started to do just a
really good job as president of the
United States just kidding I hope you
didn't zone out I'm kidding about that
what happened is that the legal noose is
sort of starting to tighten around Rudy
Giuliani it was pretty clear really more
than a year ago that the former New York
City Mayor was trouble for Trump he got
pulled off TV appearances for a while he
is now back front and center because of
his involvement in the Ukraine Fiasco
and now it really could be a tragic end
for Rudy Giuliani in the Greek tragedy
sense I used that term up for Donald
Trump's maybe personal lawyer I guess at
this point we don't really know what the
relationship is between Rudy and Trump
two of Rudy's associates have been
arrested left Parnas and Egor Froman one
of them left Parnas is cooperating and
says as I told you early last week that
he can directly and specifically
implicate Republican congressman Devin
Nunez in the Ukraine Fiasco we may have
more news about that later this week a
grand jury has now issued a subpoena for
documents related to rudy giuliani's
international consulting as he calls it
which is one of those innocuous terms
international consulting I call it
influence pet peddling and negotiating
bribery and smears and that relates to a
whole bunch of possible crimes that Rudy
may have committed we're looking at
money laundering wire fraud campaign
finance violations making false
statements obstruction of justice
violations of the foreign agents
Registration Act fara as it's known
we're talking here about both criminal
and congressional investigations into
Rudy Giuliani's work and the things that
he's done and Rudy of course denies
everything always telling TMZ TMZ found
him at an airport I think over the
Thanksgiving break and he said oh
there's no way that I'm going to end up
in prison but remember Roger stone told
me the same thing when I interviewed him
about a year and a half ago he was of
course recently found guilty on seven
counts and will be sentenced in a couple
of months heading to prison potentially
up to 20 years
realistically much much less what this
increasingly is going to be about so to
set the stage
for you for the next month's year few
years I don't really know how long this
is going to go what is going to
determine the future for Rudy Giuliani
is whether Trump abandons him or sticks
with him because that's the trend as
we've already seen happen sometimes
people throw Trump under the bus and
then Trump abandons them Michael Cohen
is one example but maybe that's not
exactly the way it happened maybe it's
more that Trump makes it clear he's not
going to stand by the person and then
they throw Trump under the bus but the
point is you have the on the one hand
people like Michael Cohen on the other
hand you've got the people like Paul
Manafort and Roger stone who have at
least seemingly remained loyal to Donald
Trump during their prosecutions and it's
still plausible that a pardon is coming
for them we don't know yet but it is
certainly plausible the real factor that
will determine rudy giuliani's future is
not did he break the law or didn't he
did he act immorally or didn't he did he
do this or did he do that Rudy is
privileged such that he is not part of
the justice system for the most of us
he's part of a different justice system
where it's who your friends are
whether it's does the president remain
loyal to you that is what will determine
the future for Rudy Giuliani he has a
get-out-of-jail-free card not in a
proverbial sense in a literal sense it's
called a presidential pardon on
corporate media they're staging these
dumb little debates about Oh does Rudy
risk having his reputation tarnished by
this scandal first of all that assumes
that Rudy had a good reputation before
this forget about that for now that's a
debate for a different day Rudy Giuliani
has become a sort of villain of the
worst intersection of influence-peddling
vulture capitalism and international
corruption and has made it clear that
what his values are are unquenchable
thirst for proximity to power money he
will use any associations at all to
further those goals it doesn't matter
what it means for the United States as a
country and that's how you end up in a
position to have to day in and day out
on national
defend the indefensible which are the
actions of Donald Trump the next couple
of weeks particularly with the upcoming
impeachment hearings there are more
starting Wednesday we'll be covering
them live on YouTube they will be
illuminating I predict about Rudy
Giuliani's role and we'll catch up about
it later this week or early next when we
actually get to see what is said at this
week's impeachment hearings